jennifer aniston enjoys a tropical  getaway with her husband Justin Theroux  et has exclusive photos of Jen and  Justin soaking up the Sun on a remote  beach in the Bahamas on Saturday the two  lovebirds who will be celebrating their  one-year anniversary in August look very  affectionate here you can see jen and  justin sharon a seaside smooch the 47  year-old actress rocked a two-piece  mismatched bikini while her husband kept  it casual with a hat and cutoff shorts  Jen's bikini pics initially sparked  pregnancy rumors but her rep slammed  those reports telling ET she's not  pregnant what you see is her having just  enjoyed a delicious big lunch and  eyewitness tells us quote Justin never  touch gen stomach specifically but they  were very romantic physically they  looked very happy together the pair was  also spotted taking a long romantic walk  on the beach and Justin even took jen  paddleboarding Jen and Justin are a real  live fairytale